I don't want to look like a misogynist  as usual misogyny is is like it's okay  to a degree  what degree let me know give me a number  at 10.  I think it depends how  different like how would you define  misogyny realism realistic a lot of  misogyny is just realizing  like if you're a realist then to some  degree you're going to be a sexist  but is that sex so is that sexist or is  that just being real right there because  like if it's a fact yeah exactly is that  sexy exactly so I I personally  I don't like traveling the world with  women I think it's one of the most  frustrating  things a man can possibly do  okay imagine you have to travel around  the world and you had to take a  three-year-old with you you'd be like  where's my three-year-old has it eight I  have to make sure they're safe gotta  bring all their stuff it's exactly the  same with the chick